someone shot me a Periscope
of a Vine
of a Snapchat of a screengrab
of a text--
[gasps]
That say they saw Cindy
pee in the shower.
- You hear that?
Your girl like them
golden showers.
I wonder if she mud sharks
in the back of the toilet too.
You already know them
Germans is on that.
- [laughing]
[smack]
- Y'all need to OJ that shit.
Cindy's a classy lady
and my future baby mama.
- [grunting]
Are you ready for some sex?
- [snoring]
- Snoring sounds like
consent to me, bitch.
[grunting]
Are you ready for my big,
fat Albert?
- Oh, shit, it's
a Bill Cosby sex tape.
- Time to put the pudding pop
where it doesn't go.
It's not rape
if she's not awake.
[phone dings]
- Oh, shit.
Cindy finally hit me back.
She must want to get wifed up.
- Say what, my nig?
- I mean, she must want
to have her cakes beat
with no emotional connection.
- Damn, I can't find
the sex tape.
- I got it,
but it ain't playing.
What the fuck is a buffering?
[crowd chattering]
- Where'd it go?
- Thanks, Obama.
- God damn it, Cosby!
What the fuck?
- Man, this is some whole
hey-hey-hey type shit.
I'ma go home and watch Ray J.
[electronic beeping]
- Whoa, what?
- I ain't getting
no data now.
- Me neither.
Damn Huxtable roofied
the whole Internet.
- I got to go see what Cindy
was texting me about.
I'll holler.
- Where you going?
- To the library, my nigs.
I know they got Wi-Fi.
- What's a li-burry?
- It's where homeless people
chill when Starbucks is closed.